[Musique]
je vous ai demandé de vous arrêter et je
n'ai rien à faire
voulais dire
vous m'avez vous m'avez frappé
mon mari frappé ça va aller très loin
comme ça il fait chaud si je vous
demande d'appeler tu peux permettre il
faut s'arrêter de tout le monde alors
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé parce qu'on a
rien compris à cette histoire tout le
monde en a parlé merci Stanislas vous y
étiez qu'est-ce qui s'est passé merci
parce que tout le monde c'est vrai que
tout le monde a parlé tout le monde a
commenté
en fait tout le monde dit Monsieur
Frémaux a agressé un policier parce
qu'il lui a demandé de s'arrêter en vélo
si Frémont fait ça c'est pas du tout
pour ça c'est parce que policier il a
tapé la collé contre le mur il y a pas
toute la séquence il y a le début de la
séquence on voit le policier l'emmener
vers le mur et le repousser comme ça ils
mettent les mains au cou je pense que
alors après on a fait le procès c'est
pas ce que je recommande je l'ai envoyé
à Pierre-Henry sur le mail est parti
après l'avion malheureusement on a
essayé de la récupérer cette vidéo de ce
qu'on me dit je te dis tout c'est toi
qui c'est toi qui m'a l'air d'ailleurs
merci
Stanislas et ce qu'on m'a dit c'est qui
roulait sur le trottoir apparemment à
vélo
sur le trottoir c'était dans la nuit de
jeudi à vendredi vers 2h du matin ou les
sur le trottoir le policier lui a
demandé à deux reprises de s'arrêter
parce qu'il y avait du monde et que
c'était assez dangereux et Monsieur
Thierry Frémaux a refusé et donc le
policier l'arrêter à l'entrée du carton
et c'est là que la carcassion a eu lieu
donc pour venir comme ça assez rapide
quand on regarde les images on voit bien
monsieur monsieur Frémont en train de
voilà de de pointer du doigt le policier
qui l'a pas forcément bien pris il
s'approche de lui de façon assez
menaçante donc le policier lui le
repousse un petit peu mais visiblement
selon les témoins alors vous y étiez à
la scène
apparemment le thierry Frémont accuse le
policier de l'avoir insulté et de
l'avoir frappé donc vous avez
apparemment une vidéo depuis le moment
mais effectivement
sur le trottoir en vélo électrique
3 minutes après il y a iPhone fort qui
est arrivé j'imagine que c'est pour ça
qu'il était pressé le policier lui
demande de s'arrêter c'est vrai il a il
se retourne vers lui et il lui monte je
sais pas ce qu'il lui dit honnêtement je
ne sais pas et personne ne sait parce
que j'étais le plus près j'ai pas
entendu et l'autre personne qui était là
non plus n'a pas entendu j'imagine qu'il
lui dit désolé je peux pas m'arrêter je
suis pressé ou peut-être il lui dit
allez vous faire [__] mais ça
m'étonnerait quand même on dit pas
désolé on dit pas désolé à un policier
désolé je peux pas m'arrêter si moi
demain je dis un policier désolé je peux
pas m'arrêter il va me mettre
un policier désolé
c'est un policier te demande de
t'arrêter tu t'arrêtes tu vas pas poser
ton vélo attends je vais voir Harrison
Ford je reviens rester là mais pour deux
minutes et après je vous parle pas comme
ça la vie c'est quand on dit laisser
d'accord avec lui il y a pas de souci
a fait une infraction bah c'est quoi
alors bah c'est que le policier du monde
de s'arrêter il s'arrête pas voilà il
s'arrête quand même 20 mètres plus loin
et il parle aux policiers et là le
policier le prend super mal et fait un
peu voilà quand on voit sur la vidéo il
fait pas vraiment le cowboy le politique
voilà regardez le début là vous voyez le
policier qui arrive là regardez
la force
la question n'est pas d'être au-dessus
les lois la question c'est qu'il est pas
en dessous la loi non plus et un
policier n'a pas à taper quelqu'un comme
ça
on connaît monsieur Frémaux c'est quand
même pas la première fois que ça arrive
il avait déjà eu il y avait déjà eu un
accident avec avec une journaliste de
France 3 région lors du festival de
lumière d'ailleurs le SNJ à l'époque
c'était c'était à l'armée parce que il
l'avait pris la caméra il l'avait baissé
violemment et voilà c'est pas très
respectueux pour les journalistes on
peut enfin voilà le le caractère de
Monsieur Frémaux est quand même connu
par les journalistes et là de ce qu'on
voit c'est pas c'est pas ce que vous
voulez vous les gardez votre arrêt de
station mais toi tu as vu tu as vu autre
chose non mais tu as vu toi c'est ta
version
moi j'ai été je n'ai aucun doute sur le
fait que le policier était
hors de hors des clous quoi
que c'était filmé il m'a bien vu en
train de filmer il m'a dit après il me
dit ça va tu as bien filmé
je te dis stade et pourquoi il est seul
de ce qu'on m'a dit c'est que voilà il a
refusé de s'arrêter et après bon à
forcement il lui a dit Gilles à deux
fois cette histoire
on est dans la nuit à 2h du matin devant
le Carlton d'accord monsieur Frémaux sur
le trottoir en vélo électrique le
policier municipal lui dit deux fois
visiblement selon les témoignages
arrêtez-vous il ne s'arrête pas il le
policier le rattrape d'accord et le seul
tort du policier à un moment excédé
c'est le bousculer monsieur Frémaux mais
quand même pourquoi la vidéo devient
virale c'est qu'on a très nettement
l'impression que Monsieur Frémaux dit
c'est moi monsieur Frémaux
le policier refuse de lui donner son nom
moi je pense qu'un citoyen normal quand
il se fait il y a un abus de
mec excuse-moi mais tu as déjà vu un
gars qui se fait arrêter qui va dire au
policier donne-moi
la commune des histoires de gens qui
sont fait abuser par des policiers qui
sont pris pour des cowboys
policiers d'une infraction mais là on
parle d'une infraction pas laquelle
monsieur Frémaux ne sait pas arrêter à
deux injonctions du policier le policier
le le va le voir au Carlton il lui et là
tout de suite monsieur Frémaux lui
demande son matricule etc alors qu'il
était en infraction normalement quand
vous êtes un citoyen normal vous vous la
pétez pas dites oui excusez-moi j'étais
pressé je suis désolé vous faites un peu
profil bas là tout de suite policier
bien on lui met une contravention on va
pas le taper on va parler on va pas le
faire
Stanislas monsieur Frémaux dit ça va
aller très loin sous-entendu vous ne me
connaissez pas vous savez pas taper qui
que ce soit
prise par cette séquence le Festival de
Cannes a été obligé de réagir ils ont
dit dans les minutes qui ont suivi une
explication franche et cordiale a eu
lieu mais enfin à l'échange le chapitre
l'eau selon la municipalité ça dit d'un
nom sujet David Lisnard le maire a dit
la police municipale de Cannes ville si
contrasté énergie effectuer toute
l'année un travail exigeant avec
impartialité conformément assez
directives à mes directives et à l'état
d'esprit auquel nous sommes attachés y
compris bien sûr pendant le festival
c'est une selle commission produit tous
les jours la vidéo fait le buzz parce
qu'elle implique Thierry Frémaux c'est
ce qui a dit la municipalité et du côté
des policiers nous rappelons à Monsieur
Frémaux qui sont comportement à vélo est
d'une part contraire au Code de la route
et qu'en outre son refus d'obtempérer
pour reconstituer un délit qui aurait pu
conduire à son interpellation et si
besoin de force en France nul n'est
au-dessus des lois pas même le délégué
général du Festival de Cannes le
communiqué il est pas mal je vous ai dit
tout est dit c'est à dire qu'à un moment
personne n'est au-dessus des lois ce
monsieur là même si il estime avoir du
pouvoir parce qu'en disant ça ça veut
dire qu'il a la certitude qui va pouvoir
punir ce vilain policier qu'il a arrêté
alors qu'il était tout chaud vers
quelque chose d'important bah non tu es
comme tout le monde tu es un citoyen
comme tout le monde face à une
infraction on se tait il aurait pu payer
30 €, il aurait pas eu de suite et pas
de problème bah va voir la vidéo dont tu
parles dans un instantané on l'a sorti
alors et ils ont dit ils nous apportons
c'est le début dont je suis d'accord
de ce que tu ne vois là voilà donc ça
c'est au début vous croyez vraiment que
le patron du Festival de Cannes il s'est
arrêté en vélo il se met dans un état
pareil parce qu'un policier
il y a eu quelque chose entre les deux
quand même là quand on voit la vidéo
pour vous et il respecte les distances
de sécurité et respectent la zone c'est
pas c'est pas monsieur vraiment là qui
va vers un policier remettez si moi je
fais c'est sérieux
pousse regardez comment il va vers le
policier si moi je fais ça au sol et si
un policier me dit de m'arrêter là je
marque vous dites quoi vous dites quoi
aux gens avec les bécanes qui ne
s'arrêtent pas quand il y a les
policiers on leur dit à maintenant aux
jeunes qui nous regardent là quand il
est policiers vous demande de vous
arrêter ne vous arrêtez pas puisque le
mec du Festival de Cannes est parti
faire son truc alors il y a des gens qui
se passe-t-il
le policier a fait son boulot c'est ça
bien sûr on a l'impression qu'au fond de
vous vous pensez que Monsieur Framer est
supérieur vous avez dit tout à l'heure
le policier est tombé sur plus fort que
lui ça veut dire quoi bah oui fort tout
à coup je vais vous dire moi j'ai plein
d'histoires de ça m'est arrivé ça vous
êtes obligé de rentrer chez vous avec la
haine que vous êtes obligé de ravaler
parce que vous êtes personne et que le
policier un uniforme il a un flingue et
vous avez épargné pu faire il a fait le
cowboy et ben je suis content que pour
une fois il y a un titre
je vais te dire je vais te dire on n'est
pas sur le vélo en trottoir le policier
il faisait rien de mal le policier en
fait qu'est-ce que tu en penses regarde
moi je prends pas du tout un policier
comme une personne
on a l'impression qu'il roulait
entre les passants
ils faisaient rien de mal il y avait pas
de problème et donc il fallait le
laisser circuler quelque chose de Stan
tu sais pendant le Festival de Cannes
déjà la police municipale ils sont sous
pression de fou
tu crois que Frémont il est passé
[Musique]
monsieur Frémaux a une tendance à se
considérer comme le patron du festival
le passant de cassis
du bien donc moi
après le policier
exactement comment ça s'est passé moi je
t'explique je sais pas moi je te le dis
l'histoire je te l'écris il était en
vélo le policier il a flippé il sait pas
qui c'est Thierry Frémaux je savais pas
que c'était je te jure le poly et il
voit ça le policier il voit ça il est en
vélo il voit un mec qui arrive en vélo
truc qui qui file il se dit bon c'est
qui qui se garent il a dû lui dire
d'arrêter une fois deux fois l'autre lui
dire attends je fais ce que je veux je
sais pas qui je suis donc il a dit
attends donc ça c'est en venimeux et
après c'est bon je te pousse du doigt tu
remets là tu me pointes du doigt je suis
policier je te pousse je suis désolé de
vous dire ça monsieur si tu si tu me
pointes du boulot
c'est pour
la police a eu des arrêts
alors on arrête on rigole oui on a
l'impression que la justice le jeu je
devrais que je trouve que Thierry
Frémont devrait avoir un traitement de
faveur non c'est pas le cas maintenant
j'en ai un peu marre que de cette
conscience culture qui dit qu'il y a un
mec qui réussit c'est forcément
[Musique]
il faut quand même dire que vu les
accusations
portent contre le policier risque aussi
sa place quand on lui dit que vous quand
il dit quand il dit que il s'est fait
agresser qui s'est fait taper ce qui ce
que ne pas du tout les images le
policier lui qui a des enfants et une
famille risque sa place
[Applaudissements]
de cette culture il tient pas oui il
faut respecter les mecs qui réussissent
mais c'est pas parce qu'on a réussi
qu'on doit pas respecté les autres mais
c'est pas parce qu'il est en cul-de-pie
qui peut insulter mais bon le mec est
m'épouser les gens je le redis encore
une fois il est devenu agressif quand le
policier l'a tapé avant
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas vrai
votre vidéo ne montre absolument plus
vite
la vidéo mais non je vous explique la
vidéo début il y a le plan de loin
repousser c'est-à-dire repoussez pas
taper pas taper voilà
ça coupe parce que je suis loin il est
il est dans l'angle et je le vois plus
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
moi je déteste les gars qui disent vous
savez pas qui je suis là franchement
mais il a pas beaucoup
en tout cas voilà ce qu'ils le font
Bernard Montiel